so in problem 44 once again we have the
exact same setup that we had in problems
42 and 43 but now they're asking us the
number of a in T sub P such as the
determinant of a is not the determinant
of a is not divisible by P well we've
already done some work in problem 43 and
figuring out some and figuring out some
set of the members that are divisible by
P so why don't we just figure out the
total number of members of T sub P and
then subtract that subtract the total
members that are whose determinants are
divisible by P and then we'll get this
answer right over here so what's the
total what's the total total members
total members in T sub P well for a I
have P possible choices right if I'm
picking between up to P minus 1 but I'm
including 0 there's actually people
choices so I have P possible choices for
a P possible choices for B by the same
logic and P possible choices for C so I
have P to the third possibility so their
total of P to the third members in T sub
P now what did the last problem what did
the last problem tell us this was
problem this was number 43 it told us it
told us the members maybe I should write
this way the number of members number
number of A's such that the trace of a
this was the language they used in the
last in the last video or the last
problem such as the trace of a not
divisible by P but but the determinant
of a is and we got the answer and we got
the answer as P minus 1 squared now if
you remember that problem and even it is
to do that problem we had to when we
thought about this statement such that
the trace of a is not divisible by P we
figured out that this was exactly equal
to saying this was exactly equal to
saying that a does not equal 0 so one
way to view the result of from 43 is if
you assume that a is not equal to 0
there are P minus 1 squared members of T
sub P where the determinant is divisible
by P so this is starting to get some
where this is we're starting to count
some of the A's whose determinant is
divisible by P but these are the only
the the matrix A's who's a entry is not
equal to 0 so if we want to count all of
them we have to also count the ones
where a does equal 0 so where a a does
equal 0 so let's think about let's think
about that case we can figure out how
many how many matrices there are where a
does equal 0 and the determinant of a is
divisible by P add it to that then we
have the total number of days that our
determinants are divisible by P and we
could subtract that from the total
number of possibilities and hopefully
we'll get one of the answers up here so
let's think a little bit about what will
the determinant to look like over here
so in this situation the determinant of
our matrix will be it's a squared it's a
times a minus B times C a squared minus
BC now we're assuming that a is equal to
0 if a is equal to 0 is equal to
negative it's equal to negative B C and
we need to think about how is this how
is this going to be a multiple or how is
this going to be divisible by divisible
by P so this is good this has got to be
equal to some multiple of P so the first
thing you just think about bees and the
C's they both they are both non-negative
so this value right here this value
right here cannot be negative so if when
you put a negative sign there it cannot
be positive so it can't be it can't be
any positive multiple so P it could be 0
so we could have negative BC we could
have negative BC is equal to 0 which is
equivalent to saying that BC is equal to
0 that's one possibility or equals 0
times P that's still a multiple or maybe
it could be negative maybe we could have
negative BC is equal to is equal to
negative 1 times P but when you think
about it here if this was true that
would mean that BC is equal to P and
that so B or C would be factors of P now
we know we
that p we know that P is a prime number
its factors are only one and P B B and C
if I mean one of these guys could be one
but then the other guy would have to be
P they can't be P they only get as high
as P minus 1 this is not an option so
the only possibility if a is equals 0
for the determinant of capital A to
still be divisible by P is for BC to be
equal to 0 so let's think about how many
possibilities there are over here so
let's think about all of the
combinations so there's one there's the
one situation where B and C are equal to
0 B and C is equal to 0 now let's think
about the other ones there's one where B
is equal to 0 and C and C isn't BC will
still equal 0 in this situation so how
many possibilities are there how many
possibilities aren't there for this well
B is equal to 0
C can be any C over here can be any
value although we've already considered
the case where C is equal to 0 so it can
be any value so that we don't double
count any value where C does not equal 0
so it could be 1 through P minus 1 or
another way to think but there's P minus
1 possibilities now let's think about C
is equal to 0 and B isn't and B isn't
well exact same logic once again we
don't want to double count they're both
being equal to 0 so let me write it and
C isn't well we're saying it isn't 0 so
we're sure are you putting that
constraint there so it has P minus 1 P
minus 1 possibilities so how many total
possibilities of how many total
possibilities do we have were the
determinant of a is equal to 0 and a is
equal to 0 so we have 1 here we have one
possibility here than P minus 1 and P
minus 1 so our total possibilities are P
minus 1 plus P minus 1 plus 1 which is 2
P minus 2 plus 1 which is 2 P minus 1 to
P minus 1 incremental possibilities when
a is equal to 0 for the determinant of a
to be divisible by P so that's what we
just got in this video in the last video
we had P minus 1 squared possibility
when the deterrent when a does not equal
0 so if we
want the total number of A's where the
determinant of a is divisible by zero we
can add the number that we got in the
last video to the number we just got so
let's do that so if I were to rewrite if
I were to rewrite this over here this is
equal to P squared minus 2p plus 1 and
then I want to add this to P minus 1
here so plus 2p plus 2p minus 1 plus 2p
minus 1 and what do I get these cancel
out these cants with that and these guys
cancel out so there's a total of P
squared P squared possible possible A's
where the determinant of a divisible by
P now we're very close this isn't what
they're asking they want the total
members that where the determinant of a
is not divisible by P so all we could
all we have to do here is take our total
our total membership which is P to the
third take our total membership which is
P to the third and subtract from that
the members whose determinants are
divisible by P and we just figure that
out we subtract P squared and now we'll
get we'll get A's the number of A's
where determinant of a not the
determinant of a not a divisible by P
now let's see if that's one of the
choices and it is d P cubed minus P
squared